[Musique]
regarde c'est ce fou de josé il nous
fait le même coup à chaque fois il est
malade ce type c'est pour nous faire
peur
bonjour la mort
essai de m'attraper pourvoir
[Musique]
mon nom est josé buteur et je suis
pilote de fumigation cela fait dix ans
que je travaille dans les llanos en
colombie il ya ma passion c'est voler
nous les pilotes de filiation nous
sommes une espèce rare car il faut avoir
du courage faut être rayons on risque
notre peau tous les jours
nous voulons un mètre du sol et à 200km
une erreur n'est pas permis tout des
centres aux études et craint un coup
l'enjeu travers et ses fatah en plus
nous transportons un produit mortel
dans ce métier en décollant et
atterrissant 40 à 50 fois par jour
la rapidité dans le travail
c'est primordial au sol histoire empire
l'avion très vite et nettoyer de paris
tant maximum au sol ne doit pas dépasser
2 minutes c'est du temps mort pour moi
au sol je ne gagne rien moi on me paye
que lorsque je décolle
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est quoi ici il n'y a pas
d'assurance dans la fumigation ne
trouvera personne qui veuille assurer
disent que nous sentons la mort
[Musique]
appelle moi le mécano s'il te plaît
après dix mois la pression du lait trop
bas en cabine j'ai l'impression qu'un
tuyau s'est rompu et si c'est le tuyau
d'essence s'affiche sans moteur et ça
peut exploser
c'est ça exactement
moi je le sentais 3 que le café je suis
désespérée lorsque je n'ai pas de
travail parce que je ne vole pas cela
m'ennuie et ça me fatigue
[Musique]
ces produits sont dangereux pour les
pilotes mais aussi pour les assistants
tous ceux qui les manipulent
mais ils sont nécessaires car si les
agriculteurs ne les appliquent pas ils
perdent leur école
c'est mon sens tu dois passer et
fumigènes et là tu vois ok ça c'est le
centre d'accord
il ya toujours de nouvelles espèces de
maladies et d'insectes qui se développe
et se régénère sur les cultures nous les
latino américains ont servons de cobayes
pour essayer les produits chimiques
qu'il lance sur le marché ces produits
qui sont interdits aux états unis en
europe il nous les envoient chez nous
[Musique]
ces produits sont très toxiques
puisque tu les insectes et les mauvaises
herbes c'est un travail délicat il faut
être très professionnel pour appliquer
les doses avec précision car tu peut
détruire toute la faune autant
en fait nous opposerons les cultures il
ya de bonnes récoltes moi c'est à cause
de cette vermine de chauny que nous
sommes obligés de fouiller les champs de
soja
sinon elle détruit toutes les feuilles
[Musique]
le soir lorsque je termine je suis
complètement épuisé comme si j'avais
joué deux parties de football à 9 heures
après avoir pris quelques bières et bien
je me trancher
[Musique]
catalyst
c'est inquiétant ici à porto lopez il ne
me reste plus que mon frère c'est la
seule personne en qui j'ai confiance
[Musique]
je me suis fait à ce village il est
pacifique
j'ai du travail les filles sont jolies
et je suis heureux ici
[Musique]
à
ce prestigieux société de loto être
pilote
ces prestigieux les gens admirent car tu
prends des risques et ils te prennent
pour un fou
il ne faut pas que le succès de monte à
la tête
au contraire il faut rester pour ne pas
perdre le contact avec les gens
[Musique]
elisabeth représente la moitié de moi
même dans mon métier je fais des folies
elle représente pour moi la paix un
oasis dans ma vie quelque part elle me
comprend
elle me protège elle me le donne tout
son amour j'ai vraiment besoin d'elle
pour exercer mon métier je n'étais pas
bien je ne pourrais pas me concentrer
dans ce travail il faut avoir une grande
forme physique et mentale des situations
de tous les dangers
elisabeth représentent 70% de mon état
mais tu me la bible l'éternel a parlé à
moïse tout ce que tu peux faire c'est le
selon des forces car dans le sait on
c'est quoi le zéro la mort lorsque je
lis la bible
j'apprends tous les jours quelque chose
elle me rassure ce qui s'est passé avec
le moteur de mon avion et le risque
s'accroît plus je dois être en communion
alors je ne crains rien il n'ya que dieu
que je crains j'ai mis ma vie entre sa
[Musique]
enfin conquérant c'est ouais j'aime pas
que josé vol dans cet avion en mauvais
état c'est un professionnel
c'est à lui de savoir ce qu'il doit
faire je connais bien son avion c'est ce
qui est bien ou pas bien
[Musique]
elisabeth c'est que j'aime coin des
filles mais ce n'est pas sérieux
[Musique]
je ne lui cache rien
notre relation est solide et chacun sait
ce qui l'attend dans de l'eau donne moi
la première lettre de son prénom et je
te dirais qui tu t'appelles le machisme
a toujours été et sera toujours cet
écrit dans la bible que l'homme sera
supérieur à la femme
j'aurai encore cassé c'est surtout en
dessous du moteur il y ait une nouvelle
fissure
c'est le mécano qui l'a dit il faudrait
que tu ailles voir tout de suite
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment abusé de sept avions l'a
fait deux mois que je ne devrais plus
voler avec ce moteur est maintenant il
tombe en panne tout le temps cette fois
ci c'est grave
une fissure tu parles
la fissure est là sous le moteur l'huile
sèche à paris 6-2 l'allemand
écoute je vais faire ce vol pour 700
francs et si je m'écrase au sol avec cet
avion
ça te coûtera 700 mille francs tu remets
3 0 7 cent mille francs c'est le prix de
l'avion
non non c'est beaucoup trop de risques
pour mon portefeuille et tu portes à vis
de toute façon les risques on les prend
tout le temps ça fait partie du travail
mais au moins que les clients paient ok
ça marche je peux me payer d'avancé
[Musique]
suicidaire il ne faut pas que l'avion
vole dans cet état c'est vraiment du
suicide
[Musique]
lorsqu'on s'ennuie dans la vie il faut
prendre des risques
la vie prend alors beaucoup de valeur
lorsque j'ai terminé le travail
je passe sous les lignes à haute tension
parfois aussi j'atterris sur la route
cela m'excite je domine ma machine la
mort je la sens proche
je joue avec elle mais je la respecte
dix ont fait une fête à l'hacienda avec
des copains tu viens je termine ce chant
et je vous rejoins j'ai encore deux
trois passages à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
josé il est vraiment dingue
à qui mais yann hausse ce sont les plus
grandes étendues d'eau tel salon
représente la moitié de la colombie s'il
ya les plus grandes hacienda du pays
pour 20 mille hectares on met dessus
vingt mille têtes de bétail capital que
failli me désarçonné avec ton avion
résultat une vache est cassé la patte eh
bien on n'a qu'à manger la vache
maintenant viens je t'invite à déjeuner
[Musique]
yann hairaud ce passe toute la journée à
cheval son cheval il londres s est le
même ils sont le symbole des llanos
comme les cowboys les états unis dix
mois on est en train de préparer mille
hectares de riz pour avril alors on
voudrait que tu me shoote cette partie
oui bien sûr
[Musique]
l'avion pour moi c'est comme pour le
cowboy son cheval je communie avec mon
cheval part à gauche tu le redresse et
bien l'avion c'est pareil
pour se faire payer par les agriculteurs
c'est tout un problème regarde cette
liste toi qui es belle ne vont pas
refuser de payer je dois aller les
chercher chez eux dans les bars et les
chercher dans les champs avec une gueule
de chien battu en plan même lorsqu'ils
me voient comme ça certains ne veulent
pas payer tout de suite d'autres me
disent qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent c'est
embêtant allait bien m'a dit ça peut
être toi ou ton père 4000 francs qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est une facture
oui de la filiation
je peux me régler avec ce que tu as des
vaches des chèvres cheikh n'importe quoi
qui est de la valeur
ma maison oui si tu as de jolies filles
à l'intérieur j'ai eu trois accidents
graves et beaucoup de mes amis pilotes
se sont tués
j'ai cassé déjà deux avions lors d'un
décollage le moteur a lâché et je me
suis écrasé sur une colline
j'ai été j'ai pris avec le siège grâce à
dieu comment s'appelait l'endroit où tu
es tombé le chemin aventure non non non
c'était une fosse à purin un jour en
plein vol j'ai rencontré un essaim
d'abeilles qui s'est engouffrée dans le
moteur saleilles tout fait et je suis
tombé de 70 m je n'ai rien eu c'est un
miracle grâce à dieu par contre l'avion
[Musique]
et
or j'ai perdu toute ma famille dans la
catastrophe du volcan d'armero et j'ai
vécu une autre tragédie ici à quarto un
être cher s'est suicidé
un jour côte est je rencontrerai jésus
qui l'emmène là haut dans le ciel
en fait lorsque je vole je me sens plus
prêt
[Musique]